what's going on everyone got a 2021
Accord um if you have a dead remote
battery this is how you're going to get
the car to start like if we look at it
right now nothing's happening um if you
hit the button you'll notice that the
engine start stop button will start
flashing at you what you're going to
need to do is get the remote and just
stick it up to it and you'll notice that
right here on the cluster it'll tell you
to go ahead and start the engine okay so
I'm going go ahead and put my foot on
the brake and hit engine start and it'll
start right up I hope the video helped
you out and if it did appreciate it if
you like subscribe you guys take care be
safe have a great weekend